now before we get going here into the
topic at hand I I got to tell you I just
stopped at the store a few minutes ago
and I was walking out to my car
and I see I mean you know I see this all
the time and anyone who's been following
me for a while you know that I've
complained about this it's not a
complaint it's more of a campaign of
awareness I have been in the midst of a
an awareness campaign for years now
about this problem but it was just it
was one of the worst I've seen I think
because it's been it's rainy here and
people are just so they get even lazier
and they just want to get back to their
cars but I'm walking back to my car
there they're just shopping carts strewn
everywhere in the parking lots all over
the blur there was even one that was
turned upside down so somebody had
turned it upside down you know so that
it wouldn't roll into somebody's car
which thank you for that but there's
also there are these cart Corral's
positioned okay you know the cart in the
places where you can return your car to
there's like seven of them positioned
all throughout this parking lot so that
no matter where you're parked you could
not possibly be more than like twenty or
thirty feet from one of them yet even
the twenty or thirty feet is too far for
people to walk so they just they said
I'll just leave my cart here I'll even
turn it upside down
maybe but most people just leave it like
I'll just leave it here because it's
rainy and windy and I don't wanna have
to walk twenty or thirty feet well guess
what it's rainy and windy that means
that the wind is gonna come and blow
your card which has wheels and it's
gonna blow it probably into somebody
else's parked vehicle and cause damage
to their vehicle because you are too
lazy to walk twenty or thirty feet or
got it now you might say well what if
I'm in a parking lot where they don't
have cart Corral's I don't have to walk
all the way back to the store and return
it to the store oh my goodness what a
what a tragedy that would be the you
might have to walk forty feet then forty
whole feet how could you possibly manage
to do that well I'll tell you how you
manage to do it you I mean how whatever
process you followed in order to get the
cart to begin with just do that again
repeat that process and whatever you did
however you managed whatever whatever
whatever magic trick you had to pull in
order to initially come in contact with
that cart do that again in Reverse
and Lee and it's so and and and that's
how you could put the card away it's
really not that difficult
this is now if you want to if you want
this is the there is no greater evidence
of the of the disintegration of human
society then shopping carts that people
just leave all over a parking lot
anyway um I wrote a piece on Friday
published Friday night and you know I
was making a point about the the
scandals in in the Catholic Church
and as I as I and I want to try to
elaborate on this argument if you didn't
read the piece or even if you did point
that I was trying to make is that the
sex abuse scandal in the church is is is
not a pedophilia scandal okay the
problem isn't pedophilia unlike what
we're told and what you hear in the
media about all the so-called pedophile
priests and so on the problem is not
pedophilia the problem is gay priests in
the church and the statistics bear this
out this is not me this is not a theory
that I'm positing this is just a fact
it's really indisputable this is what
statistics show and most prominently
there was something called the John Jay
report that was I think the most
extensive report published on the sex
scandal in the church and it shows that
the vast majority of victims the vast
majority of victims were male and the
vast majority were not prepubescent
children and pedophilia by definition is
the sexual assault of a prepubescent
child so by definition most of this was
not pedophilia
and then on top of that of course every
single perpetrator was male obviously so
what does that tell us that tells us
that what happened in the church and
it's may still be happening to some
extent is an epidemic of gay men
assaulting mostly teenage boys now it is
true that that very same study that I
mentioned the John Jay report it you can
there are there are people who are
looking to absolve the gay priests and
so they will point to that very same
study because that study did also try to
claim that homosexuality had nothing to
do with the assaults although it said
statistically that the majority of cases
this these were these were men
assaulting teenage boys or post
pubescent boys they said in the report
well but it had nothing to do with
homosexuality had nothing to do with
orientation
but this is an assumption I think a a
ridiculous assumption that is not borne
out by the statistics
what what the researchers tried to say
is that well yes this was all
male-on-male stuff but it wasn't because
of orientation but how could that
possibly be the case
you mean a man who molest your old boy
doesn't have a homosexual orientation
then what does he have if that's not a
homosexual orientation then what is it
and of course
this problem encompasses more than just
the assault of minors homosexuality is
rampant in the priesthood there was an
article in Slate few years ago which is
and I and I cite this because it's far
from most conservative publication but
an article in Satan's lates
adapted from a book called the sex
effect which details how homosexuality
became so common in the priesthood and
now they now they say it's between 15
and 50 percent of priests are gay now
that's a really wide margin okay between
15 and 50 percent and I think that 50%
is probably overstating it considerably
but the point is that homosexuals are
are significantly over-represented in
the priesthood
in comparison to society at large
and this is a process that really kicked
into high gear as it were in the 60s and
70s
so the priesthood started to become a
haven for gay men in the 60s and then
also in the 60s the molestation of altar
boys started to become a huge problem
so in the 60s you've got
homosexuals who start to join the
priesthood and the priesthood becomes
becomes
becomes a a haven for homosexuality and
then around that same time you've got a
bunch of teenage boys who are being
molested and assaulted by priests is it
is it is it possible to see a connection
between those two things
we possibly connect them maybe
is it just a coincidence that gay
priests exist in such large numbers
protected by gay cabal's
in the church and at the same time there
happened to be a bunch of priests
molesting pubescent boys
can we really claim that those two
realities are completely distinct and
separate and that there is no bridge
connecting them whatsoever
let's consider let's taking a
consideration the case of Cardinal
McCarrick
is one of the most prominent Cardinals
in in the United States and the world
really and he's been I think he's in his
70s maybe older now so he's been around
for a long time he's been accused of
preying upon young boys including an 11
year old boy so he has been accused of
molesting boys so this is another
example of minors being assaulted but
when those accusations started coming
out and then all this other information
about Cardinal McCarrick came out most
of the stories that have come out about
him revolve around his sexual exploits
with seminarians and seminarians are
grown men in their 20s so it's probably
true that he did he was grooming and
molesting boys but we know that he was
he was also involved in a lot of sexual
activity with grown men yet
we're told that his homosexuality is
irrelevant
or even according to the media and
according to apologists they'll even say
well he's not a homosexual because he's
interested in children well but if he's
not a homosexual then why is he involved
with all these grown men as well
in fact all of these priests was of who
have who have assaulted boys you tell me
you really think that they haven't also
been involved with men as well
I mean how could that be if Cardinal
McCarrick were not a homosexual
then isn't it true that he would not
have molested boys how could we possibly
dispute this and that's not to claim
that all homosexuals molest boys but
that is to claim that among men only
homosexuals molest boys a non homosexual
by definition would not be attracted to
males so even if they even if a non
homosexual is a scumbag sex predator
there are plenty in that category
heterosexuals who are also scumbag sex
predators but they're not going to go
after boys because they're not attracted
to males because they're not homosexuals
a lot of people for some reason have
been angry at me for saying this and
they've claimed that well a man who
assaults a minor can't be gay because
sexual assault is about power it's not
about sex so these are men who want
power and nothing more but this of
course is absurd and you hear this a lot
about about sexual assault well sexual
assault is all about power it's not
about sex it's not about orientation
well of course it's about all of those
things what do you mean it's just about
power that's ridiculous if there are
plenty of people out there who who enjoy
having power and lording it over others
and manipulating and coercing there are
a lot of bad people like that but there
are many ways to achieve power and
domination over another person without
getting sex involved into it so if you
do achieve that power through sex then
that tells me that there's something
about the sex itself which obviously you
enjoy so it is also about the sex 80
percent of the victims in the church
have been males 80 percent so is it
difficult to see how thousands of boys
would have been spared this experience
if there had not been so many
homosexuals in the priesthood is that
difficult to understand why do we have
so much difficulty with this
am I saying that by getting rid of the
homosexuals in the priesthood we could
all but solve the problem of sexual
assault in the church yes that is
exactly what I'm saying and this that
eighty percent eighty percent of the
victims are males 100 percent of the
perpetrators are males so if there were
no homosexual priests then those victims
who were males would not have been
victimized obviously or are we going to
pretend that even a heterosexual may
decide to molest a fifteen year old boy
is that what we're going to pretend now
for the sake of absolving the gay
priests and absolving homosexuals of
everything are we gonna actually pretend
that and if so then honestly I have no
idea what the words heterosexual and
homosexual even mean anymore and I guess
that's part of the point is that we're
not supposed to know what any words mean
because they mean you know whatever
whatever essentially the left needs them
to mean in the moment
by the way you can accuse me of
homophobia all you want but it's not as
though I am one who ignores cases of
heterosexual abuse no in fact I think
I'm one of the only people in America
who is not ignoring the epidemic of
mostly heterosexual abuse in the school
system I talk about that all the time
hardly anyone else talks about it
there's basically no public interest in
the in in this epidemic and I have not
been able to drum up hardly any public
interest I mean I wrote a I wrote an
article all about the sexual assault
epidemic and I had all the statistics
and they are startling shocking
horrifying statistics of just how
prevalent sexual assault is in the in
the school system and I wrote about this
you know a couple months ago and I think
the article got like 10,000 views nobody
cared nobody nobody just nobody's
interested they just don't care they
don't want to hear about it
but not for lacking not for lack of
trying on my part sex abuse in the
schools is is many times more common
than it is in the Catholic Church and
this is this mostly consists of men
assaulting girl students and women
assaulting boy students this is a big
problem too and what do I say about that
I say and I have said many times that
look it's probably not a good idea to
have women in their 20s teaching teenage
boys just like it's probably not a good
idea to have men in their 20s teaching
teenage girls and it may be true that we
don't have much of a choice in the
public school system and and and that
probably is accurate but there are there
are serious problems inherent in this
arrangement and we are seeing those
problems bear themselves out so ideally
you know the ideal environment for
education would be to segregate boys and
girls and have them in completely
different schools and especially when
you get into the older grades with the
older boys and the older girls in those
grades you would have men teaching the
boys in almost every case and for the
girls you have you would have women
teaching the girls that would beat now I
know that that is not for public schools
that's not feasible it's never gonna
happen but I'm saying that that is the
ideal scenario and when you start mixing
when you take heterosexual
women in their 20s and you have them
teaching 16 year old boys
it is not I'm not theorizing that maybe
that could lead to problems I am
observing that it has led to an enormous
amount of problems
same when when the gender when the
genders are reversed
in a similar way
and look this is not there's this really
stupid thing people do where they they
look at a reality like the reality I'm
talking about now and they'll say yeah
but you know it shouldn't be that way I
mean it shouldn't be that we you should
we should be able to have 25 year old
women teaching 16 and 17 year old boys
and Monisha be able to do that without
any sexual activity happening which we
should be able to yeah we should be able
to but we are not able to okay that it
that should be the case but it is not
the case it's just not again I'm not
making this up this is just the this is
what's happening so we can either
acknowledge the reality and adjust
accordingly or we can just plunge ahead
you know making no changes whatsoever
and then nothing gets better in a
similar way it is not a good idea to
have homosexual men living together in
seminaries and rector ease and working
closely with teenage boys it is not a
good idea this again is not a homophobic
theory of my part this is just a fact
and so if it's homophobic at all it is a
homophobic fact it is not a good idea it
will lead to problems and we have seen
those problems in the Catholic Church
bear themselves out for 50 years we have
seen the problem manifest itself
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times for 50 years this is what happens
when you take homosexual men especially
when they're supposed to be it's
supposed to be a religious environment
of celibacy and chastity and you put
them all together in a you know in in in
houses together then you have working
with teenage boys this is what happens
it is simply moral cowardice
to hide from us it is moral cowardice
and when I've been talking about this
over the last few days I have been
scolded many times by Mike supposed
Christians and even yeah I've gotten a
few messages from priests I've also
gotten messages in support of what I'm
saying from priests and from laypeople
but I've got plenty of messages on the
other end of that spectrum saying how
dare you how dare you say this how dare
you how dare you slander all of these
gay priests how dare you implicate
homosexuality in this scandal how dare
you I am so upset at you okay
it may it may make you feel better to
wag your finger and you know take the
side take take sides with the world and
say oh no we must never say anything
critical of homosexuals at all ever I
know that makes you feel better and I
know that it does but you're being a
coward you're just being a ridiculous
coward and you know it
because you know that what I'm saying is
true
it's the there is there is no argument
against it
it's just the reality
and there are so many I mean the church
when I say the church I mean the
Christian Church I mean Chris and um
Christianity itself in the West
everybody it is it is it is infested
with moral cowards
who simply will not stand up and say
even the most self-evident truths
if those truths are politically
incorrect
one other point about this
and I think it's important for us to
realize because I've heard from some
Protestants who say who say oh you know
I'm so glad this doesn't happen in
Archer I mean this is a Catholic problem
you know this is what happens with
Catholics I'm so glad this isn't a
problem in our church
well they say the problem in Protestant
churches - this is a problem as why I
say this is a problem in in in Christian
among Christians in the West especially
mainly read briefly from a New York
Times article the three companies that
insure a majority of Protestant churches
say they typically receive upward of two
hundred and sixty reports a year of
children younger than 18 being sexually
abused by members of the clergy church
staff members volunteers or congregants
in Protestant churches two hundred and
sixty a year
which actually averages out to more than
have been victimized in the Catholic
Church
so this is a big problem in Protestant
churches - it's not taught nobody talks
about it just like with the public
schools and nobody talks about it no one
discusses it nobody seems to care
because we have focused all of our
energy on the Catholic Church but the
reality is this is a societal problem
that has bled into all of the churches
back to Jesus saying you know don't look
at the speck in your brother's eye you
got a log in your own well it just so
happens that among Christian churches
they all have logs in their eyes and so
you we all got a look at the logs with
each Church has to look with at the logs
within its own eyes you know this is a
problem in society we see all you know
so we see it in the in the religious
institutions obviously we've seen it in
media and Hollywood we see it in the
public school system it's a societal
problem
although
the Christian Church should stand above
these problems
should be a shining light an example to
all
is not what is happening
because also over the last 50 60 70
years
Christianity in the West has kind of
allowed itself to sink down into the
muck and the mud with secular culture
and has become in so many ways an
extension of secular culture
not something that transcends it or
stands above it or leads it or guides it
and this is one terrible symptom of that
from
so it's time for us to just look at the
reality of the situation to face it
to act accordingly
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed